[Music]
[Music]
this character for a long time that's
been probably like eight years or more
and you know it's so much has happened
in my life and the former happen in my
life personally and I think that you
know it would be theirs I love playing
this character and I think that there is
definitely an opportunity to explore the
widow as a woman who has kind of come
into her own and is making independent
and active choices for herself
probably for once in her life you know
she hasn't always had that had that
possibility so if it fit though that
criteria they don't yes why would she
help build this time it's like you would
have a reason for it and you'd only do
it if there's a reason a good story and
I guess no interest in making something
other than that
we're seeing a black widow movie in the
works which I hear about it is so
exciting and Captain Marvel with brie
Larson and Wanda wise so we are seeing
that women are at the forefront of these
stories and of course with black panther
that you know those incredible warrior
women in that film so I think audiences
will be pleased to know that yes the
future of Marvel seems to be pretty
female and I've got this completely
under control but why everything's on
fire Marvel has had an extraordinary
fanbase you know for many many many
decades but now with these movies
they're just so well done when with with
the intertwining of all the characters
and then the entire MCU and so to have
us all here tonight is pretty epic and
it's gonna be just such a I don't know
I'm kind of gonna geek out a little bit
I'm so excited to see it
[Music]
the jury so you can do anything I'd like
to see her kind of venture out a little
bit more out of what kinda a little bit
more and help different you know going
different missions around the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we need to see more women stories being
told being greenlit there is absolutely
no - to it and I think that that's
something that is being slowly more and
more realized and proven without a
shadow of a doubt
[Music]